salut bon aujourd'hui vous l'avez
compris j'ai envie de demander c'est
quoi la can seule culture c'est un sujet
à la fois épineux est d'actualité qui ne
rend pas la tâche facile vous invite
donc à prendre tout ce que je vais dire
avec des pincettes et je me réserve la
possibilité de faire une sorte de post
scriptum vidéo au cas où de nouveaux
éléments me viennent à l'esprit
j'espère être assez prudent ici en tout
cas bon en gros a qu'une seule culture
c'est le nom que certains ont donné à
une forme de militantisme
je ne sais pas qui a inventé le terme je
vous encourage à l'enquêté
ce que je crois pouvoir dire en tout cas
c'est que ceux qui utilisent cette
expression sont généralement plutôt
contre il me semble qu'il existe des
militants qui se revendiquent de cette
appellation
mais je n'ai pas l'impression que ce
soit majoritaire
c'est quoi ce militantisme une
définition qu'on trouve sur la planète
c'est délaissement ou ostracisation
d'une personne célèbre par son public ou
sa communauté pour un non respect des
normes du groupe
on l'appelle aussi parfois culture de
l'interpellation culture de la
dénonciation culture de l'humiliation
publique ou bien culture de l'annulation
et du rééquilibrage
bref s'il fallait identifier le noyau du
truc
on pourrait dire pour simplifier que ça
revient a déclaré on veut plus voir
trucmuche sur le plateau de thé
l'émission de télé où on ne veut plus
lire les papiers de machin bidule
dentelle journal et ce pour des raisons
explicitement politique
schématiquement parce que trucmuche a
dit un truc raciste ou parce que machin
bidule a dit un truc misogyne parfois on
a l'impression d'entendre uniquement des
dégâts à ce truc moche mais ce qui est
vraiment dit au fond c'est nous croyons
après avoir aussi sérieusement que
possible réfléchi au problème que vous
monsieur truc muche représenter une
force nocive pour l'idéal politique que
nous défendons ou pour la société idéale
que nous visons ce qui est quand même
beaucoup plus rigoureux ça reste très
schématique je reconnais et ça laisse en
plus de côté la question des motivations
mais pour l'instant je veux m'en tenir à
cette version simplifiée parfois il faut
le rappeler ça revêt d'autres formes un
peu plus spécifiques comme la volonté
d'enlever tel statut de tels
esclavagiste parce que c'est insultant
pour les descendants d'esclaves
et puis en france
surtout vu le cas polanski qui a fait
beaucoup parler même si je trouve ça un
peu différent parce que pour le coup il
est ici question d'accusations relatives
à des crimes et d'ailleurs cette
dimension a été un peu masqué parce que
visiblement on a préféré se poser une
question traditionnelle pour les
critiques littéraires à l'université ou
en philosophie de l'art peut-on séparer
l'oeuvre de l'artiste question qui s'est
rapidement transformée en une version
encore plus compliqué faut t'il séparer
l'homme de l'artiste c'est quand même
très très difficile
la notion de devoir ne simplifie pas la
tâche en plus et peut-être que ça nous a
éloignés des vrais enjeux
on aurait peut-être pu tenter une
formulation plus ouverte du type pour
quelle raison une société pourrait-elle
promouvoir ceux qui enfreignent ces lois
je crois que ça aurait été plus
intéressant mais je ne vais pas
m'aventurer là dedans pour le moment je
voudrais m'en tenir à la dimension
purement idéologique de la cancel
culture et mettre de côté les cas qui
font appel au droit et donc je ne peux
pas rentrer dans le débat du type oui
mais tu comprends polanski il a jamais
été reconnu coupable en france et c'est
donc je mets de côté les accusations
relatives au cadre légal pour le moment
j'en parlerai brièvement la fin de la
vidéo
désolé si vous êtes déçu bien sûr
aucunement besoin de le cacher soyons
plutôt transparent je ne fais pas partie
de ceux qui ont peur de la dit quand
cette culture et je vais essayer
d'expliquer pourquoi j'ai en tout cas la
sincère impression que les raisons que
je donne ne tiennent pas tellement à des
intérêts disons spécifiquement liée à ma
situation sociale je ne peux pas vous le
trouver mais c'est ce que je crois
sincèrement je vais essayer de présenter
pourquoi je n'ai pas trouvé de raisons
convaincantes d'être inquiet devant
cette dynamique militante
bon déjà remarquons que ceux qui
n'aiment pas à cannes cette culture dit
souvent de trucs d'abord faut arrêter
avec l'hyper politisation
c'est à dire qu'il ya le sous-entendu
que des combats politiques viendrait
contaminé des espaces non explicitement
politiques ou des espaces qui devrait
rester indépendant du militantisme
politique
c'est l'idée que certaines choses
devraient être toujours protégé en
quelque sorte de l'action militante
comme par exemple la culture ou les
sciences et puis ensuite c'est de la
censure
sarah contre la liberté d'expression
j'espère que je n'ai pas fait d'hommes
de paille et que j'ai été assez
charitables
moi il ya quand même deux trois trucs
qui me gêne là dedans pour le premier
point sur l'hyper politisation
je ne connais pas vraiment d'arguments
solides pour limiter clairement le champ
politique pour définir ses contours la
politique c'est l'organisation de la
société
donc en gros faut pas se leurrer la
politique ça concerne tous grosso modo
tout ce qu'ont fait nos hobbies nos
métiers
notre consommation c'est dans la société
et tout ce qu'on fait ou ne fait pas
d'ailleurs a donc des impacts directs ou
indirects sur la vie des autres
toutes nos actions s'inscrivent dans une
organisation collective croire que la
science ou la culture pourrait évoluer
hors des questions politiques
ça semble super naïf la culture c'est
une économie des institutions ces
véhicules et des idées des sentiments
c'est promouvoir une manière de vivre
une façon de voir le monde c'est donc
éminemment politique
quant à la science c'est sans doute un
peu plus compliqué j'en parlerai dans
une autre vidéo en préparation sur les
sound soir mais pour le moment disons
ceci si le scientifique peut prétendre
travailler indépendamment des questions
politiques
ce serait au sens où l'essence de son
travail est apolitique
parce que sinon son travail est pris au
sens large est effectivement mêlés à des
institutions des universités des
financements publics et privés etc
l'activité scientifique prise dans son
ensemble concerne la société
tout simplement mais donc même si on
concède que disons l'essence de la
recherche scientifique serait apolitique
le fait même de considérer son activité
comme indépendante de la question
politique est du point de vue de ceux
qui considèrent que la question
politique est importante
un positionnement politique c'est
logique non dire dans mon métier je ne
m'occupe pas de l'organisation de la
société
ce n'est pas une de mes préoccupations
c'est pour ceux qui subissent les
défauts de la société pour ceux qui
aimeraient bien qu'on travaille à
corriger ces défauts parce que ça leur
pèse au quotidien pour ces gens là oui
c'est un positionnement politique ça dit
un peu en sous-texte je m'en fous que
vous souffriez les défauts de la société
je préfère me concentrer sur ce qui
m'intéresse parfois on a un peu
l'impression que certains défendent tout
simplement leur droit à ne pas s'occuper
des injustices de l'organisation sociale
dans laquelle ils vivent
il n'est donc pas anodin que
généralement ceux qui s'indignent contre
l'as cannes cette culture soit des gens
qui ne souffre pas énormément du système
en place
c'est ce qu'on aborde dans la troisième
vidéo sur la rationalité demandez-vous
d'ailleurs si vous êtes plutôt contre
est ce que je serai pas parce que
finalement le monde dans lequel je vis
me convient plutôt c'est la question
politique par excellence le monde mais
thil favorable où la société telle
qu'elle est organisée est elle favorable
à mon mode de vie
c'est ce qu'on dit aussi dans la vidéo
sur la perspective la manière dont on
expérimente la société détermine notre
désir de la transformer si on dit
arrêtez de tout politiser
c'est peut-être parce qu'au fond on ne
ressent pas effectivement l'urgence
qu'il ya à corriger les défauts de la
société c'est une autre question
fondamentale sa ressentons d'urgence de
corriger les défauts d'organisation de
la société
si c'est pas le cas ça pourrait vouloir
dire qu'on passe à côté du sens de
l'action militante du sens même de la
politique en fait car elle n'a aucun
sens de cette phrase
arrêtez de tout politiser on politise
exactement ce qu'on veut c'est
précisément ça la démocratie
si un groupe de gens se dit concernée
par une cause il en fait par définition
une réalité politique c'est le jeu on
peut pas faire son marché dans ce qui
est politique ou non
c'est la société qui décide et pour
l'instant on vit dans un système qui
maintient l'idée qu'un groupe social
peut se constituer pour faire valoir un
droit ou un désir relatif à
l'organisation de la société
si on nie ce truc là ça me parait chaud
donc en théorie on devrait tout
simplement en tant que membre d'une
société plurielle qui reconnaît la
valeur de cette pluralité de voix pour
la santé de la société elle même
reconnaître l'existence de ces
revendications et s'interroger sur la
meilleure manière de composer avec elle
au lieu de ça on dirait que l'idée qu'il
puisse y avoir des désirs différents
vis-à-vis de certaines réalités de la
société entendu comme entité idéologique
et les culs comme une menace et
d'ailleurs ça serait pas un peu
paradoxal comme refus se serait pas
faire exactement ce qu'on reproche à ce
militantisme c'est à dire tenter de
contenir un discours de le limiter
ce serait finalement intimement
contradictoires vu que l'argument
données en général est souvent un
principe si par principe il ne faut pas
empêcher les gens de parler alors il ne
faut pas non plus empêché de parler les
gens qui militent pour le droit
d'empêcher les gens de parler il paraît
quand même pas fou de dire que la
démocratie doit pouvoir laisser vivre
dépenses et antidémocrates en son sein
sans les interdire
si une démocratie interdite la pensée
anti démocrate
qu'est ce qui la distingue
fondamentalement au moins dans son
rapport à la liberté d'expression d'un
régime autoritaire
le deuxième point a dit que c'était la
question de la censure
alors d'abord la liberté d'expression
pour rappel ça veut juste dire qu'on ne
sera pas arrêté pour un truc qu'on a dit
ça veut pas dire que les gens sont tenus
de vous donner une plateforme pour vous
exprimer ou qu'on est censé vous écouter
il ya inscrit par fèves qui explique
cela un éditeur choisi ce qu'il publie
un journal se donne une ligne éditoriale
c'est normal si je soumets au figaro
magazine une tribune anti sarkozyste et
qu ils la refusent pour des raisons
idéologiques du genre on n'est pas tout
à fait en accord avec votre tribune
monsieur le patient zéro ça n'aurait
aucun sens de dire quoi et ma liberté
d'expression bordel j'ai vu ce tweet qui
m'a plu on peut en effet concevoir que
cette liberté d'expression s'accompagne
d'une forme de responsabilité quant à
notre prise de parole dans l'espace
public surtout d'ailleurs quand on sait
qu'on est diffusée à grande échelle
on entend parfois laisser les gens
s'exprimer
même s'ils disent des erreurs même s'ils
disent des conneries ça finira par se
réguler de soi même fait confiance au
processus démocratique
ça ressemble un peu j'ai l'impression à
une partie de l'argument de chomsky
vis-à-vis de faurisson
en gros pour aller vite c'est à dire que
c'est aux historiens de montrer que
faurisson dit de la merde pas à l'état
de lui interdire de dire de la merde
c'est probablement pas la totalité de ce
que dit les choses qui y un mais c'est
une petite partie de son argument et je
suis pas trop à l'aise avec elle parce
qu'en fait le souci ici c'est que
l'occupation de l'espace public n'est
pas également répartie il n'y a pas
d'autorégulation en fait la liberté
d'expression absolue où on aurait accès
avec autant de facilité à toutes les
opinions qui font le corps social
c'est un pur fantasme et il faut
reconnaître que l'organisation des
structures de diffusion joue un rôle
central dans la vie publique des idées
donc tout simplement dans ce qui va
modeler l'opinion des gens il suffit de
voir la proportion des espaces
médiatiques occupés par des gens comme
zemmour enthoven ou finkielkraut
ces gens ne sont pas sérieux personne
n'a jamais pensé qu'ils étaient vraiment
intelligents ils disent grosses bêtises
sur grosse bêtise eh bien on voit bien
ça ne se régule pas tout seul
la liberté d'expression ne suffit pas à
elle seule à compenser le fait que ces
gens là prennent de plus en plus de
place à la télévision ou à la radio et
continue de dire des trucs très souvent
très bête
les plateaux télé ne sont pas plus
intelligents mesurer et rationnelle
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne l'étaient il ya 50
ans donc il faut peut-être tempérer
notre optimisme relatif à la capacité du
système en place à faire circuler et
diffuser les idées les plus fines et
intéressante que la société produit donc
les militants disent non seulement ces
gens qui occupent la télévision et les
journaux racontent des conneries grosses
comme tout présente des idées
caricatural et ridicule en fait pour
quiconque a la moindre forme d'exigences
intellectuelle mais en plus ces
conneries véhicules des idéologies
toxiques participer un système injuste
et soutiennent des logiques de pression
d oppression soit dit en passant dont
les victimes sont grosso modo toujours
les mêmes le soutien peut être plus ou
moins directe plus ou moins conscient
mais ça ne change rien le fondement de
ce militantisme tient ce diagnostic on
dit en gros vos prises de paroles
reconduite des injustices c'est pas si
différent avec la science par exemple
dire
laissez les scientifiques débattre entre
eux c'est important quand la science de
ne pas interférer dans son évolution
c'est un peu compliqué c'est peut-être
vrai pour les publications scientifiques
en peer review mais dès qu'un
scientifique publique ailleurs chez un
éditeur sur un blog
s'ils passent à la télévision peu
importe il s'inscrit dans l'espace
politique et il est soutenu
c'est à dire publié diffusé par des
structures publiques ou privées qui
relève de réalités politiques
économiques institutionnels etc
on l'a vu avec le professeur arrow
pendant le confinement c'est pas sans
conséquences mettons que monsieur x
scientifiques de renom dans son livre
paru chez le grand éditeur et non spe ou
paix est une réflexion sur la société
mais tant que pour appuyer paix en bon
scientifique monsieur x a fait appel à
des données d mettons maintenant que
madame y scientifique peu connus comme
la plupart des scientifiques se rend
compte que paix est fondé sur une erreur
et que les données des sont incorrectes
madame y corriger l'erreur de monsieur x
dans son blog ou sur sa chaîne youtube
ben en fait c'est trop tard le mal est
fait le livre de monsieur x est tirée à
100 mille exemplaires et monsieur x a
fait la tournée des plateaux de tv ou
bien sûr on n'a pas manqué de
l'interroger sur p et les gens qui sont
convaincus par ce que dit monsieur x ne
feront pas souvent l'effort la démarche
d'aller chercher des contradicteurs
l'idée paix se diffusent dans la société
et contribuer par exemple à consolider
le système en place et personne n'écoute
madame y parce que personne ne la
connaît elle n'a aucune audience cette
sympathique madame y
qu'est ce qui vous fait si vous avez la
franche impression que monsieur x à une
diffusion disproportionnée et qui
soutient un système qui vous est
constamment défavorable
logiquement vous dites il y en a marre
de monsieur x
c'est pas tellement plus compliqué que
ça et si vous êtes nombreux ont fini par
vous entendre parce qu'il faut
comprendre que le système politique
dominant est comme toutes les
organisations entre humains organique
je veux dire par là qu'ils cherchent à
perdurer ils cherchent à se consolider
aussi
les idées qui vont dans son sens les
auteurs qui soutiennent le système qui
le défendent plus ou moins consciemment
sont plus souvent retenue accepté
diffusé on leur donne un espace pour
s'exprimer
on peut voir les choses ainsi le système
politique est fait par des esprits
humains et il fonctionne comme un esprit
humain il est méga sujet au biais de
confirmation
il suffit de regarder ses news le figaro
bfm tv le nouvel obs marianne l'express
le point les grands pôles médiatique ne
font jamais de place à des chroniqueurs
vraiment dissidents qui dirait des trucs
contraire qui voudrait attaquer le
système en place
qu'on soit d'accord ou non reconnaissons
qu on entend peu voire très peu les gens
qui représentent les positions les plus
opposés au système
on n'est pas dans une interrogation
sincère des organisations alternatives
potentielles
de là naît une décrédibilisation
progressive de toutes les positions
véritablement antagonistes j'ai la
sincère impression que tout ce qui dit
il faut changer le système temps être
présentée comme une position naïve et
irréaliste
d'ailleurs vous avez peut-être remarqué
on dirais même qu'on a fini par nous
faire croire que la révolution c'était
forcément un fantasme d'adolescents ou
alors un truc de radical sociopathe
terroriste qui veut tout voir péter en
mode joker du coup c'est internet qui
peut jouer le rôle de petit grain de
sable qui embête ceux qui ne veulent pas
spécialement voir le système changeait
internet c'est loin d'être parfait
évidemment est très souvent ça sert le
système dominant
mais voilà malgré tout il y à des
mouvements qui se forment des
militantisme qui se construisent et
parfois on les entend bien quand ce
n'est pas une histoire de liberté
d'expression le reproche est souvent
formulé ainsi ses militants mettre la
pression il pousse pour que la société
aille dans le sens qu'il souhaite
bon jusque là c'est normal c'est ça le
militantisme politique
tout le monde a plus ou moins envie que
la société du soin favorable milité ces
s'activer pour tenter de faire que cette
société idéale à laquelle on rêve
devienne effectivement
ou au moins qu'on s'en rapproche donc du
coup ceux qui critiquent ajoute oui mais
cette fois ça va trop loin
on peut comprendre ce sentiment mais
comment savoir si le trop loin
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas le progrès de
demain
après tout quand les esclaves voulait
s'émanciper
les producteurs de coton disait ça va
trop loin quand les femmes voulaient ce
droit de vote les mec disait non mais là
ça va trop loin quand les homosexuels
ont demandé le droit de se marier et
d'avoir des enfants
la manif pour tous a dit un an mais là
ça va trop loin et donc je terminerai
par un truc certains ont sûrement envie
de répondre oui mais parfois quand même
il ya des injustices il ya le cas de
monsieur z qui a été viré de tel journal
pour avoir dit un truc qui n'était pas
faux simplement parce que ce truc
n'allait pas dans le sens de la
politique que veulent ces militants eh
bien d'abord oui ok le militantisme peut
produire des injustices en tentant de
corriger des injustices saahlm c'est
relou c'est vrai mais en même temps si
on ne fait rien on laisse les injustices
habituels se produire on ne peut pas
reprocher à quelqu'un qui corrige 10
injustices dans provoqué 2 si on veut
vraiment attaquer ce qu'on appelle la
can cette culture il faut être capable
de démontrer que ce militantisme produit
plus d'injustice qu'il n'en corrige ce
qui n'est pas simple
finalement c'est ça la rationalité
politique on vise le moins mauvais on
n'attend pas de trouver un système
éthique et politique absolument parfait
et sans défaut pour agir
on tente on essaye on corrige ici on
corrige là certains diront peut-être que
c'est justement ce qu'ils font aussi en
critiquant ses militants que c'est une
espèce de régulation mais dans ce cas il
faut s'assurer qu'on le fait de manière
productive et pas simplement répété
censure y perdre politisation à tout
bout de champ ensuite il faut voir quels
sont nos priorités
est-ce qu'il est plus important de
défendre le droit de monsieur x a
continué de publier des ouvrages tirés à
cent mille exemplaires
ou est-ce qu'il est plus important de
s'attaquer aux rouages de l'organisation
sociale qu'on a oublié de remettre en
cause par habitude et qui génère
pourtant beaucoup de souffrance et
d'injustice
en tout cas un bon sens l'enjeu du débat
il est là plutôt que de réfléchir à coup
de grands principes généraux peut-être
qu'il faut tout simplement se demander à
propos du mouvement
qu'est ce qu'il essaye de corriger est
ce qu'il y arrive
qu'est-ce que ça risque de produire et
surtout surtout parce qu'il est absurde
de parler de risque dans l'absolu
quelles sont les probabilités associés à
ce risque
s'indigner sans avoir mis les pieds un
peu sérieusement dans cette partie du
problème
c'est manqué de rigueur rationnelle si
j'ai échoué à faire un style man ou si
j'ai manqué de charité herméneutique
dans cette vidéo c'est pas par mauvaise
volonté mais par incapacité
intellectuelle pour l'instant même
venant de gens pas bête du tout j'ai
toujours par en tomber d'arguments
contre la dit quand cette culture que je
trouve vraiment convaincant et je n'ai
pas réussi à en imaginer moi même
le seul truc que je vois c'est la
crainte assez naturel finalement d'une
dérive et l'accent mis sur les
dénonciations calomnieuses du genre
monsieur z est un criminel alors que
monsieur z est innocent oui bien sûr on
n'a pas envie que des gens soient
injustement accusés mais justement c'est
le moment de se poser la question en
termes probabiliste quel est le risque
que cette dérive fasse plus de dégâts
que l'état actuel des choses il est bien
possible qu'on ait de la main donc
comment penser une situation aussi
incertaine si madame x dit que monsieur
z la violer on peut en appeler à la
présomption d'innocence pour ce qui est
de la situation légale de monsieur z
on dira on ne va pas mettre monsieur z
en prison sans faire une enquête sans
qu'il y ait eu un jugement mais en tant
que monsieur z est un individu qui tient
une place importante dans la société
parce que c'est une personnalité
publique ou parce qu'il a du pouvoir ou
parce qu'il est célèbre monsieur z a une
fonction symbolique une fonction
politique et symbolique
il représente quelque chose il
représente une forme de succès c'est à
dire quelque chose que notre société
reconnaît et promeut peut-on prendre le
risque de continuer à promouvoir
quelqu'un qui est accusé de quelque
chose que la société doit chercher
collectivement à éliminer donc c'est
déjà important de comprendre que du seul
fait de cette réalité symbolique
il est normal que la société prenne en
compte l'accusation quand bien même la
justice ne s'est pas encore prononcée
peut-on prendre le risque de soutenir
collectivement quelqu'un dont la
fonction symbolique pourrait devenir
toxiques
tout dépend bien sûr de l'importance
qu'on donne à l'accusation de madame x
mais je crois qu'on peut traiter ça de
manière rationnelle
par exemple on peut confronter les
hypothèses et les estimations si
monsieur z est accusé de viol il y a
malgré tout beaucoup plus de chances
qu'il ait violé madame x que le
contraire au sens où une écrasante
majorité des gens qui n'ont violé
personne non effectivement jamais été
accusé de viol on peut le dire ainsi les
probabilités d'être accusé de viol en
ayant violé personne sont a priori très
faible et la proportion d'hommes
susceptible d'agresser sexuellement une
femme m'apparaît plus élevé que la
proportion de femmes sujettes à de la
mythomanie aiguë en somme il y a plus
d'agressions que de fausses accusations
si on prend en compte cette mise en
relation statistique j'ai l'impression
on peut relativiser le danger terrible
de la can seule culture en tout cas
vis-à-vis du problème précis de
l'accusation injuste le danger existe
mais il est probablement pas monstrueux
bon je m'arrête là une seconde parce que
c'est important
reprenons le cas polanski le fait qu'il
y ait eu 11 autres témoignages depuis la
sphère de 77 doit être sérieusement pris
en compte l'hypothèse selon laquelle ces
onze femmes mentent n'est pas crédible
du tout d'un point de vue rationnel
c'est extrêmement peu probable
de sorte que cela suffit à faire une
preuve non pas une preuve judiciaire
puisque ces témoignages ont lieu hors du
cadre d'un procès mais une preuve
rationnelle c'est à dire quelque chose
qui doit déterminer notre croyance
il serait complètement irrationnel que
notre opinion sur polanski ne change pas
après avoir pris conscience de ces
témoignages ont ce témoignage c'est une
preuve suffisante pour que la société
s'interroge sur la place qu'elle veut
donner à polanski
c'est une preuve suffisamment solides
pour dire que des institutions doivent
refuser de célébrer polanski ont ce
témoignage cela veut dire que les
chances que polanski est violée et ou
agressé des femmes sont très très élevé
il est donc logique de considérer que la
société prend un risque terrible en
récompensant publiquement un individu
sur qui pèse aussi lourd soupçon
elle prend le risque de diffuser l'idée
selon laquelle il n'est pas si grave
d'être un agresseur sexuel puisque
visiblement ça n'empêche pas d'avoir du
succès
alors ne nous trompons pas de combat on
a besoin de preuves judiciaire et d'un
procès en bonne et due forme pour mettre
un être humain en prison mais on n'a pas
besoin de preuve judiciaire
seulement de preuves rationnelle pour
décider de ne pas donner un césar à
polanski
bon je rappelle que tout ça est à
prendre avec des pincettes
je ne suis sûr à 100% de rien je n'ai
qu'une intuition insuffisamment fondés
sans doute sur le fait que ce
militantisme est encore loin de faire
plus de mal que de bien
et pour l'instant je n'ai pas trouvé
d'éléments qui m'a dit que le contraire
de manière convaincante
si vous avez des éléments probants je
suis preneur à la limite ça peut faire
une vidéo supplémentaire
salut